>> Sandra: FOX NEWS ALERT ON
PROGRESS ON THE COVID 19 VACCINE
IN FRONT OF AS IT REPORTS VERY
POSITIVE RESULTS FOR AN EARLY
HUMAN TRIAL WHICH DID SHOW THAT
PEOPLE GIVEN ITS POTENTIAL
VACCINE GENERATED ANTIBODIES TO
THE VIRUS.
JOINING US NOW IS ALEX AZAR,
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECRETARY.
HE READ THROUGH THE DETAILS THAT
MADEIRA HAS RELEASED, ITS STOCK
IS SKYROCKETING 17% TODAY.
MARKETS ARE UP IN ANTICIPATION
OF THIS AS WELL.
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT THIS
COULD BE THE GAME CHANGER THAT
COULD LEAD US TO HAVE VACCINE BY
END OF YEAR?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP’S LEADING
OPERATION WARP SPEED WHICH IS
GOING TO PUT BETS ON SEVERAL
VACCINES.
THIS ONE WAS ACTUALLY INVENTED
HERE AT NIH AND WITHIN EIGHT
WEEKS, WE HAVE BROUGHT THAT THE
CLINICAL TRIALS, REALLY HAS TO
WORK AS YOU SAID, SOME VERY
PROMISING DATA SHOWING THE
VACCINE PROVOKES WHAT ARE CALLED
NEUTRALIZING ANTIBODIES THAT
ATTACK THE VIRUS CREATED SO JUST
REALLY IMPORTANT ADVANCE AND WE
ARE GOING TO BE PUTTING OTHER
BIG BETS ON OTHER VACCINES SO WE
ARE NOT GOING INTO BATTLE WITH
JUST ONE SHOT.
>> Ed: TALK ABOUT NEXT STEPS
THERE AND A MULTIPRONGED
APPROACH HERE BECAUSE WHILE
YOU’VE GOT OPERATION WARP SPEED
ON THE VACCINES, YOU ALSO HAVE
STATES REOPENING PIECES OF THEIR
ECONOMY, OUR OWN PETE HEGSETH
HAS BEEN AT A GYM TO GIVE YOU
ONE QUICK ADMIT EXAMPLE AND
INITIALLY THEY WERE STANDING
OUTSIDE AND WERE GOING TO SHUT
THIS GYM DOWN AND NOW REPORTING
THAT THEY WENT INSIDE, SAW
PEOPLE WERE SOCIAL DISTANCING,
AND DESPITE THE GOVERNOR’S
LOCKDOWN ORDERS, THEY’RE GOING
TO LET THIS GYM MOVE FORWARD.
TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
IN TERMS OF BALANCING REOPENING
THE ECONOMY AND MAKING SURE
PEOPLE ARE SAFE.
>> I’M GLAD YOU ASKED ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE SO OFTEN, WE ARE
DESCRIBING THIS AS A CONFLICT
BETWEEN HEALTH VERSUS THE
ECONOMY.
I SEE THIS AS HEALTH VERSUS
HEALTH.
THEY WERE A VERY SERIOUS HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES FROM BEING LOCKED
DOWN FOR EXTENDED PERIODS.
WE’VE SEEN REDUCTIONS IN
CARDIOVASCULAR PROCEDURES, WE
HAVE SEEN INCREASES IN SUICIDE
RISK, WE HAVE SEEN REDUCTIONS IN
CANCER SCREENINGS AND PEDIATRIC
VACCINATIONS.
THESE ARE REAL AND SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES, WE HAVE TO
BALANCE THAT AGAINST THE HEALTH
BENEFIT OF STAY AT HOME, AND WE
BELIEVE THINGS TO THE
PRESIDENT’S HISTORIC RESPONSE
THAT WE CAN GET BACK TO WORK AND
BACK TO SCHOOL WITH APPROPRIATE
MITIGATING STEPS TO RESUME OUR
LIVES AND RESUME THE GREAT AND
IMPORTANT WORK OF OUR ECONOMY.
>> Sandra: WHAT EVIDENCE HAVE
YOU SEEN SO FAR THAT THE
REOPENING OF SOME AREAS OF OUR
COUNTRY IS GOING WELL AS YOU
HAVE PREVIOUSLY SAID?
IS IT TOO EARLY TO TELL OR IS
THERE CONCLUSIVE EVIDENCE THAT
THINGS ARE LOOKING UP?
>> IT’S THE RIGHT QUESTION.
I WOULD SAY IT’S STILL TOO EARLY
TO TELL IN TERMS OF DATA, SO WE
HAVE STATES LIKE TEXAS AND
GEORGIA WHICH ARE REOPENING,
FLORIDA WHICH DID NOT DO SEVERE
OF A LOCKDOWN WHERE THE DATA
TRENDS SEEM TO BE GOOD WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF CERTAIN
CONCENTRATED OUTBREAKS LIKE MEAT
PACKING FACILITIES, BUT IT IS
STILL TOO EARLY TO TELL.
I THINK IT’S ONE OF THE
BRILLIANT PARTS OF THE PRESIDENT
STRATEGY HERE OF RESPECTING
FEDERALISM.
YOU HAVE THE DIVERSITY OF
APPROACHES AND STATES, AND THAT
WILL REALLY BE A LABORATORY FOR
US TO SEE WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN’T WORK.
WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT, BUT WE
WILL BE CAUTIOUS AND APPROPRIATE
THAT WE HAVE TO WORK TO GET THIS
COUNTRY BACK TO WORK.
>> Ed: THERE WERE OTHER PARTS
OR MAYBE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS TO STEP IN FOR EXAMPLE WHERE
WE SEE THIS SYNDROME IN CHILDREN
PARTICULARLY IN NEW YORK BUT
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY,
THERE WAS ONE NINTH GRADERS
SAYING THAT IT FELT LIKE SOMEONE
INJECTED STRAIGHT UP FIRE INTO
THEIR BODY, AND DOCTORS AT AT TH
HOUR AT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF
IT’S RELATED TO COVID, WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
WHAT DOES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
KNOW ABOUT THIS SYNDROME AND
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO MAKE SURE
KIDS ARE SAFE?
>> IT IS FORTUNATELY A VERY RARE
SYNDROME, COMPARABLE TO WHAT WE
CALL KAWASAKI SYNDROME.
IT’S AN INFLAMMATORY RESPONSE
ESSENTIALLY YOUR BODY IS GETTING
PROVOKED BY THIS FOREIGN BODY,
THE VIRUS THAT’S IN IT AND OUR
IMMUNE SYSTEM CREATES THIS
INFLAMMATORY RESPONSE, AND THIS
IS A RARE OUTBREAK, BUT WE ARE
WORKING ACROSS THE WORLD WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AND OTHER HEALTH
MINISTRIES TO GATHER DATA ON
THIS TO STUDY TO SEE WHAT DO WE
KNOW, WHAT ARE THE BEST
TREATMENTS FOR THIS, AND HOW DO
WE HELP THESE KIDS WHO GET IT?
TO MATT CONSIDERING THAT AND
DR. FAUCI’S WORDS ABOUT HOW WE
HAVE TO BE SO CAREFUL WITH HOW
THIS VIRUS BEHAVES IN PARTICULAR
HOW IT BEHAVES IN CHILDREN
STILL, WE DON’T KNOW A LOT, HOW
HOPEFUL ARE YOU THAT KIDS WILL
BE ABLE TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL IN
THE FALL?
>> WE WILL HAVE TO SEE HOW THE
DISEASE PROGRESSES OVER THE
SUMMER, BUT I’M QUITE HOPEFUL.
I THINK WE NEED TO GET BACK TO
SCHOOL.
THERE WERE WAYS THAT WE CAN
BRING BACK OUR ECONOMY AND BRING
BACK OUR LIVES AND SMART
SENSIBLE WAYS.
TAKE SCHOOLS FOR THE EXAMPLES
THAT YOU RAISED.
AND MAYBE MINIMIZE AUDITORIUMS
AND BIG GATHERINGS AT SCHOOLS,
AND MAYBE WE ARRANGE OUR SEATING
IN CLASSROOMS APPROPRIATELY.
BUT THERE ARE STEPS THAT WE CAN
TAKE THAT ARE SHORT OF LOCKING
OURSELVES IN OUR HOMES THAT
ALLOW US TO FUNCTION AND GET
BACK CLOSER TO NORMAL AS WE
PROGRESS EVEN AS UNDER THE
PRESIDENT’S DIRECTION WITH
OPERATION WARP SPEED, WE BRING
THERAPIES TO MARKET, WE BRING
BACK THEMES TO MARKET AND WE
HAVE THE WORLD’S BEST TESTING
SYSTEM NOW IN PLACE.
>> Ed: YOU SPOKE VIRTUALLY TO
THE WORLD HEALTH ASSEMBLY, THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION AT THE
CENTER OF THAT AND SAID TODAY,
ONE MEMBER TRIED TO CONCEAL THIS
OUTBREAK.
I THINK EVERYONE PRETTY MUCH
KNOWS YOU ARE POINTING THE
FINGER AT CHINA.
PLEASE EXPAND UPON THAT AND LET
US KNOW, THE PRESIDENT HAS CUT
OFF FUNDING THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IN PART BECAUSE
THEY HELPED CHINA COVER ALL OF
THIS UP AT THE BEGINNING.
AS THE PRESIDENT GOING TO CUT
OFF FUNDING OR NOT?
>> I AM NOT GOING TO GET AHEAD
OF THE PRESIDENT MAKING AN
ANNOUNCEMENT BUT AT THE
PRESIDENT’S REQUEST THAT I
DELIVERED A STERN WARNING AND
MESSAGE TO THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION TODAY, WHICH IS
THEY ARE IN NEED OF SIGNIFICANT
STRUCTURAL REFORM.
THEY’VE GOT TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION OF THEM, BUT THEIR
CONDUCT TOWARDS CHINA HERE AND
TRYING HIS CONDUCT HAS GOT TO BE
ON THE TABLE.
CHINA CONCEALED INFORMATION
ABOUT HUMAN TO HUMAN
TRANSMISSION, THEY DID NOT
REVEAL THE ASYMPTOMATIC
TRANSMISSION OF THIS DISEASE,
AND FOR A MONTH AND A HALF WHILE
I PERSONALLY FOUGHT TO GET CDC
IN WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
PEOPLE INTO CHINA TO LEARN THIS
KIND OF EVIDENCE, THEY RESISTED
FOR AN ENTIRE MONTH AND A HALF,
PRECIOUS TIME WAS LOST WHEN THE
COMMUNITY COULD HAVE BEEN
LEARNING AND CONCEALED VIABLE
ISOLATES AND OTHER EVIDENCE THAT
WE NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO TREAT
PEOPLE AND PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
THIS DISEASE, AND THEY SHUT
THEIR OWN CITY DOWN WHILE HAVING
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO FLY AROUND
THE WORLD SEATING THE REST OF
THE WORLD WITH THE VIRUS.
IN >> Sandra: FINALLY, WHEN IT
COMES TO FINGER-POINTING,
OBVIOUSLY, WE ARE LOOKING AT
CHINA AND WHAT HAPPENED THERE
BUT HERE AT HOME, THE
PRESIDENT’S OWN ECONOMIC ADVISOR
HAS GONE ON THE RECORD POINTING
FINGERS AT THE CDC FOR EARLY ON
WHEN HE REFERRED TO AS BAD
TESTING.
HE SAID IT SET US BACK.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT THIS
MORNING?
>> THE COMMENTS REGARDING THE
CDC ARE INACCURATE AND
INAPPROPRIATE.
THE CDC HAD ONE ERROR WHICH WAS
IN SCALING UP THE MANUFACTURING
OF THE TESTS THAT THEY HAD
DEVELOPED.
THERE WAS A CONTAMINATION THAT
DIDN’T AFFECT THE ACCURACY OF
THE TEST, JUST LEAD TO
INCONCLUSIVE RESULTS, THEY FIXED
THAT WITHIN WEEKS AND GOT IT
OUT.
THAT WAS NEVER GOING TO BE THE
BACKBONE OF TESTING, THAT IS
THROUGH PUBLIC HEALTH TESTING.
WHAT WE NEED IS THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO DEVELOP THE TEST, GET
THEM IN THE MARKET, GET THOSE
HIGH INPUT TESTS WHERE HE IS
DELIVERING OVER 10 MILLION TEST,
12.9 MILLION WILL BE DONE IN
JUST THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS,
THAT IS THE PRIVATE SECTOR
BRINGING US TO BEAR, THAT IS NOT
THE CDC THAT IS LEVERAGING THIS
WHOLE GOVERNMENT APPROACH THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS MARSHALED HERE